grant cardone probably the most famous
or one of the most famous money makers
and money trainers on the planet thanks
so much for being on the show thank you
thank you have me I appreciate what
you're doing on YouTube I know how hard
it is to build an audience and deliver
great content so well done thank you I
appreciate that one of the things I
really wanted to ask you was I know
you're a real-estate guy yeah and you
also our sales guy and I teach property
I think that it's sales this is such an
important skill so I just wanted to ask
you about why is sales such an important
skill to learn and involved your voice
being someone with so I you know like I
think a lot of people think that I'm
just naturally a sales person but I
actually hated sales I started in sales
when I was 16 17 years old and hated it
yeah didn't actually learn how to do it
until I was 20 I guess I was 25 so lost
my first five or six jobs in sales
didn't really know how to connect with
people didn't know how to control a
selling situation I didn't I mean I
didn't nobody taught me any of this so
why would I be good at it right so I
just thought because I was no good at it
then it wasn't for me yeah you know kind
of like if you give me a guitar right
like yeah I'm no good yeah I don't know
how to play guitar or violin so I must
not but I'd have to learn how to do it
and so all I can tell people is that
sales saved my life like literally like
I had a drug problem from 16 years old
to 25 when I got out of the treatment
center of a drug addiction the only job
I could get was a sales job I threw
myself completely into that job
I learned it studied it like all the
time and energy I wasted in drugs
I threw it into like I'm gonna learn
this like it became my new drug yeah and
it not because it was like it wasn't
like a drug it's about analogy but I
needed something to throw myself into
and also needed money because I was
broke so I found a good product the
company the company hired me
I sold the product did I I learned how
to sell and I fell in love with it and
today I'm known as
you know written multiple books of sales
I've made I've made other companies
billions and billions of dollars without
exaggeration like I'm not using I never
dropped the B word lightly because I've
respected but I've affected hundreds of
billions of dollars of sales for some of
the biggest companies in the world and
surprisingly enough because you brought
the real estate yeah the real estate
game that I play today we're buying real
estate I'm not a seller of any our real
estate I buy real estate buying real
estate in America is the sales game ok
the kind of real estate that I'm buying
I'm trying to buy real estate that he's
not gonna be competing on this real
estate deal the my competition is going
to be Goldman Sachs yeah
Blackstone it's not like real estate
here where there's three guys a dentist
chiropractor a business guy in town
they're buying they're buying maybe a
flat or two you know the my competition
is the wealthiest people on the planet
not not people companies and so these
are all extremely extremely smart bright
sophisticated people
so my deal thanks run appreciate it
or you know I'm buying a jet for fifty
million dollars dude that's it when I'm
buying a jet I got to negotiate the jet
yeah yeah on another story of how you
get into good shape with the pilots yeah
you've got it so fast you like the
fastest jet bar in the world probably
yeah I think I think I should get credit
for the fastest jet buyer in the world
sales really is about getting what you
want I called Gulfstream two Christmases
ago and said I need a jet we don't have
one and then suddenly they delivered one
yeah how did they find something they
said they do you learn the skill of
making fast decisions or is that
something that you feel that you're born
with because that's something that
you're young yet you make such fast
decisions yeah yeah I mean is that
something you can learn you better learn
it yeah better learn how to make fast
decisions because this the the the camp
the town of maybe goes nowhere yeah so
all of you out there that have
agreements to slow down talk to your
wife about it talk to your husband about
and talk to the account on it by the
time you you're talked to two or three
people I've already about the deal yeah
you're not moving fast enough and you're
not moving fast enough because you don't
know what you're doing
yeah you're not being careful you don't
know what you're doing so the fastest
way to reduce risk is to know what
you're doing for instance this week we
put four pieces of property under under
contract in the last three days that
I've been here without being there how
do i buy sixty seven million dollar deal
fifty seven million dollar deal fifty
five million dollar deal and a sixty
eight million dollar deal for deals
could be worth about three hundred
million dollars how do i buy those from
here call the guy up on the phone I'll
pay this much more then then you want
yeah anytime I'll pay that much more
I'll give you 250 grand non-refundable
the day they when they execute this
piece of this letter yeah I still have a
bunch of due diligence I have to do but
either way you keep the 250 when you
present like that you close deals now
now I'm not being reckless so I need to
know something the only way to move fast
is to know something I'll give you an
analogy of driving a car right you drive
you you you go in some place where
you've been before you've been there a
thousand times you can go fast right you
know where you're going you don't need a
quote yeah I saw a video that you did I
like buying real estate huh and you were
driving around driving on the area
finding fallen tenants on how much rent
you pay and really getting your hands
though doing the due diligence talk to
me a bit about my show yeah that's about
knowing where you are yeah so so when we
drove out to this estate I don't know
where I am doing like like I had a GPS I
had a map I had a guy in the back
telling me something we still didn't
know for sure so everybody's in mystery
when you're a mystery you slow down so
the way to get out of mystery is you got
to work you got to do the work yeah
right in the video that you saw us we
were in Houston Texas I think tough that
was the video we looked at five thousand
apartments in three days five thousand
five thousand apartments it represented
15 properties I Drive on the property we
were moving making right turns the
entire time we violate every property
okay it doesn't matter if they got a
gate or not we're gonna get in
I don't need a password I don't need
permission I will get I will violate the
property and so that they can let me in
I'm coming in either way we're getting
in and so what I'm doing is I'm shopping
that property I'm gonna talk to some
tenants I'm gonna I'm gonna collect data
I'm not gonna buy that property but I'm
collecting data I might not even I might
not even buy in that market but I still
want to collect the data yeah so so you
got to move fast you don't need a
spreadsheet spreadsheets are for people
that don't know what they're doing
yeah you need the data in your mind so
that when you drive on that one piece of
property you're like this is the one I
want
yeah the four pieces of property that we
put in a contract this week to get those
four I've looked at 400 so that I could
be like I want that piece of property
yeah
and I'm willing to overpay to get that
be surprised there's almost like a about
somewhere cuz some people we call them
motivated idiots where that oh my gosh
properties great and they go out and
they'll buy blind and they're really on
fire but they're not educated people do
you know like that but most people are
not hurrying into a purchase they're
taking too long to ever make one yeah
would you agree with that yeah would ya
yeah because the other extreme is
thinking I need to cross all the eyes I
got to check it with my lawyer I got to
check with this person if the lawyer
knew anything about real estate he'd own
it
I got to check with the broker the
brokers don't even own the real
interested your brokers don't own real
estate what do you think is it a good
deal
yeah it's a good deal why do you buy you
got the listing on it yeah like you
could buy the thing and you're not why
not
so do you think people's problem is that
they just don't like action and then oh
no I think I think what happens is they
yep they don't take action why you know
I did a guy did an event here I guess a
year ago with Nick James yeah I don't
eat well yeah and I said hey who's in
real estate here everybody in the in the
in the place raise your hand I said well
how many of you have cash in the bank
and everybody in the room raised you and
I said you guys don't love real estate
because if you love real estate if you
know real estate the way I know it you
wouldn't have any cash in a bank you
have all your cash yeah in real estate
people weren't sure yeah they're
speculating like like so we
piece of property I mean we could look I
could sit here with you for three hours
and just talk about real estate
so because I'll there's nothing I love
them when the real estate probably not
even like if you said hey real estate or
your youngest child I buy anything I
think I'm gonna take this [ __ ] to the
last because I know she's gonna leave me
yeah that real estate will never leave
me
you know if I this property they were on
cuz it's been in this family over a
thousand years five thousand acres over
a thousand if a license come on man this
is this is the thing that will last
longer than Facebook
what do you love more property or sales
Oh properly really all the sales Oh 1
million times more that's why because
man like it's real yeah you know says
sales is like nobody likes sales sales
is something you have to have though if
you want to get the deal yeah so when
I'm behind a piece of real estate I have
to sell the guy yeah I have to sell
convince him I got to convince the man
to give me a loan yes
if I'm raising money I got to convince
people to support me and and and and
back it with their money yeah so and I
got to sell myself that it's the right
thing to do now my advantage is I'm
buying properties that when I buy them
they start producing cash yeah so it's
like it's like I'm buying the Golden
Goose
already know it makes gold go question
for you I know the US and the UK are a
little bit different yeah I did a
challenge last year where I started all
over again from scratch and and
documented my journey of starting again
building up my property portfolio again
and it went viral on YouTube if you were
doing the same challenge where you're
starting again because I know you buy a
lot of big stuff high entry barriers
yeah you starting all over again and you
had nothing yeah that would be your
strategy I'd buy exactly what I'm buying
today would you yeah for sure how would
you because the stuff that I'm buying
today is guaranteed to be there tomorrow
it's guaranteed to produce cash flow
yeah it's guaranteed to have a buyer in
ten years I'm open to people i watch you
see the stuff that's cheap okay I have
to sell it to somebody in this cheap
interested and the people they're cheap
are always depending upon the economy
I'm selling to people that don't depend
on the college they don't care if
there's a brexit yeah Barclays does not
care if there's a brexit an exit a brat
they don't care they don't care if it's
a prime minister or King just for anyone
that doesn't know what what do you
what's your portfolio consists of what
is it well we we buy it we're buying
80 million dollar complexes seventy
million dollars these are these are
great locations lots of jobs around it
and there are properties when I buy a
property already know who I'm I sell it
to I know when I buy it that I I know
there's three or four targets yeah
that'll be bars would be a life
insurance company they're never out of
money they buy in every cycle up you
know they they always have money do they
have to they have to take they sell life
insurance they get premiums for the life
insurance and then they have to
distribute the death benefits when the
person dies and the way they do that is
they back it by the kind of real estate
that I mine
okay that's how that that's how they pay
out the life insurance so I'm buying
stuff that and this is a piece of real
estate calculation that most people
never do right Robert Kiyosaki didn't do
this like who's the exit who's the
target you're selling to and we know
when I'm buying something I'm like I
know I know who's gonna be the buyer
Goldman Sachs is gonna be the buyer
Blackstone Barclays big life insurance
companies so I always know I have a
seller a buyer so that I can make money
yeah so you you find your lips even it
really Wow yeah and if I if I was broke
I didn't have any money was gonna bounce
and if I didn't have any credit let's
say I ruined my credit yeah
don't ruin my reputation - no okay good
so my reputation is intact my credits no
good and I don't have any money I would
raise money to cut by the kind of stuff
that I'm at right now
but the crazy thing is I mean you have
caught on capital yeah which is a
fantastic service for people that don't
necessarily have the knowledge that want
to get a return some people don't
understand why when you've got money and
you're you know a millionaire a
multi-millionaire why would you still
take other people's money
the only invest that into property so
what would you say to that what
why would you borrow someone else's
money when you've got money yourself
because I'm already born somebody else's
money like I'm already using a bank yeah
so rather than making the banquets I'm
gonna make other people rich yeah the
bank clearly likes lending me money yeah
so they've lent me about six hundred
million dollars so they like lending me
money and they like being paid back okay
and they love the kind of real estate
that backs the loan so rather than
making Goldman Sachs richer or Barclays
richer yeah I'm like hey why do I make
the 7 billion people on this planet of
which 10 million of them know my name
yeah and love me and follow me so why
don't I tell the 10 million this never
existed for it three years ago I could
not go on Facebook and say I have a deal
and you can fund it with me we can
partner together what could you don't do
that because dude what one the the laws
didn't allow me to and five years ago
social media didn't exist yeah there was
no way for me to go have my own TV
channel right within such an opportunity
now that on so many levels for people to
be able to get in to business
entrepreneurship because of things like
social media the way the economy is so
but you understand like like legally in
America anyway I don't think I think the
same thing is true here yeah legally in
America and I'm not confined in America
we have money coming in from India South
America Russia England yeah so so I can
go online today I can go do a live
LinkedIn or YouTube or Facebook or
Instagram like like it's not even one TV
channel I could have seven yeah TV
channels and go out and say hey guys
here's the property on buy this is the
debt this is the income what partner on
it I'm gonna give you your share I'm
gonna keep this little piece over here
for me because I did the deal do you
want in or not infinite return okay and
so in and how many people are in the
world that don't have the time to buy
real estate don't have the credit don't
have the money but they can come in for
ten thousand or a hundred thousand now
why would I do that because I can I can
build
I can build a much bigger portfolio yes
and the reason I want to build a bigger
portfolio is because the bigger this
thing gets Wales want to eat play
No I'm going for a whale kill here so I
want to build a big portfolio where 10
or 15 or 20 billion that I can take to
one of these big banks and say how would
you like to have the whole thing at one
time
yeah that's cry I love the model and
rescue a question you're great at making
money that's and you're also great at
teaching other people how to make money
besides that what do you want to be
remembered for
you know just if if you know I'd love to
be remembered for somebody to help
people you know that somehow inspire
people to think different if my kids run
into to you you know years from now and
say you know III and I'm not around
anymore
amen I like the time that I spent with
your dad he was an authentic guy who's
transparent he's you know I mean
nobody's gonna remember me because I
bought a bunch of real estate yeah maybe
some real estate yet but but everybody
else is gonna say hey that guy helped me
on YouTube well I mean I've my
accountant told me that day's like why
are you spending all this time on this
other stuff why don't you spend 100% of
your time buying real estate there's so
much money to be made in this space
we've got billions of dollars not not
tens of millions billions and billions
of dollars and so he's like why do you
help why do you spend all this time
helping me why do you spend time doing
podcasts you know and I'm like because
it helps people then yeah when I was 16
years old I wanted somebody desperately
to help me I wanted somebody like you
yeah to take time with a kid like me and
there was nobody taking time with which
people hides rich people at MIT tell me
what that means
rich people hide man these these uh you
know that y'all know it here in England
better than anybody because of the class
thing yeah you know nobody gets to look
behind the you know behind what what
does the Queen really do over there no
one knows you know what do they do other
than what they show us I want to know
what's really going on I remember I
watched a friend of mine I spent some
time with he he had sold the company was
worth four billion dollars he cashed out
he had 4.4 billion and I said look man I
need one thing from he's like what do
you need man I'll do anything for you I
said I just want to see the money and
he's like what do you mean
I want to see your accounts I want to
see the fidelity account I want to see
the cash account I want to see your
checking account
he's like I should have met he opened it
up and and I'm sitting there dude I was
freaked out I was like I had never seen
that many numbers that many zeros one
account had 411 million in cash I had to
read it over and over again because it
was one account like I'm like 411
million that inspired me some people
resent that they're like he's got too
much it didn't do that to me it inspired
me to say man food how much good is that
guy gonna do that guy has given away a
hundred million in a weekend Wow to
cause us yeah so so that just was very
inspirational to me so hey I hope people
remember that I helped a lot of people
know part of our world tour is going
around meeting people yeah
what's your house it jet by the way it's
great it's well it what's your vision
then now I notice you got Navy but your
jet you're flying all over the world
what's the reason that you get up in the
morning you know - because I want to
find that next the next part of me man I
want to find you know I want to stay
excited about what I can possibly pull
off one of the things I love about you
is you just say exactly as it is you
know you just you just speak it's
totally to the point which is really
helpful congratulations on hitting a
million subs on Eugene yeah yeah
thankfully that's that's megasaur knew
that yeah [ __ ] though right because I
mean I you know when we started that
YouTube channel I guess that was 11
years ago I I didn't know how to do the
channel how old are you 28 yeah so you
know I'm twice your age and we start a
channel and just start to drop in
content I didn't know I was supposed to
ask for subscribers I didn't know how to
tag yeah I don't know how to title stuff
so we've just botched it for 11 years
but you know the beautiful thing about
YouTube is that it just lives on you
know I love YouTube oh it's my favorite
I love you without a doubt is that your
favorite platform so should we talk
totally I thought it's been the most
dependable for me like yeah I get more
traffic from YouTube than Facebook and
Instagram because I just think that when
I
you're starting all over again you said
to us to love my reputation yeah
it's so important don't Asia people ask
me why they YouTube and of course it's
same as you it's because I want to help
people but also dude if I went broke I
would be more public because people will
be more popular why would you be more
popular because I'd go on and say hey
man I [ __ ] up yeah check this out I
[ __ ] up I lost everything
yeah okay let me tell you what I learned
from it and everybody would love me I
would have more likes people have people
afraid people are afraid to fail yeah
people think if they fail then because
in school things about yeah you're in
the game though you're in you know you
got to be in the game and if you're
willing to share you the problem with
social medias it's okay to share the
losses it's not okay it's like people
are not happy when I when I do big yeah
they're not they're not terribly like
when you put your jab I bet you got high
on that Oh totally they're like I had I
had a family tell me they owned seven
Jets and they told my wife the wife of
the rich dude told my wife you know we
looked we looked you up online didn't
know who you were and we saw you guys in
the jet that's really surprising to us
that you show yourself on the jet I'm
like what am I supposed to hide that
picture like what people wouldn't take
they don't take pictures on their trips
so we just happen to do a video the jet
was in the shot yeah if I was getting
off of a era of British Airways so I can
put that in I can't put this in you guys
got seven Jets you don't show him to
people at the same time she's got a
broach on it's a carriage it's like that
big yeah it had to be a million dollars
all right and she's wearing around
showing her to her friends right yeah so
it's good enough for her friends but not
good enough for the public
and and my promise to to the people that
follow me is I if I said if I ever make
it I'm not gonna hide yeah I'm gonna you
know this is my life dude and you show
what you're buying and what you're doing
and it's it's great to say
yeah and like like when we we got we
were leaving Tyler we were trying to get
in a Tyler sold out yeah I didn't know
that we needed to call Thailand and said
we're coming in and get a 7-day permit I
didn't know that so we couldn't fly the
plane in so we had to get it we got it
on a commercial flight oh woe is me
so the whole family had to get on a
commercial flight yeah we were in the
back row I showed that to so you know
here's the guy with with a jet paid for
and I can't even use it so you know all
the glitters is not gold yeah absolutely
well what would you what advice would
you give to someone then that was just
starting out in their entrepreneurial
journey member that'd be real estate
what best advice would you give someone
everybody wants that one best piece man
you gotta go but you know think think
bigger than you think
yeah crying I'm really grateful to
having you on it's great to get to know
you a little bit I'm coming down to the
States in July I'm coming on one of your
any program oh good yeah book table
dinner and stuff like that good man
look forward to that can't wait to get
to know you better thank you so much
Frank thanks for what you doing Jess
thank you
[Music]